hallo leute ich es mit eurem wanne und
willkommen zu diesem neuen test video
warum freue ich mich so sehr wie es
richtig gelesen habt ich werde heute
jedes gepäckstück und starbucks testen
das ist einer dieser momente wo ich
einfach nur dankbar bin für diesen
unfassbar geilen job danke letzten zwei
monate stand main kanal ja eher unter
dem stern fitness sport disziplin und
neue routen finden was ich auch mega gut
finde und weitermachen werde denn ich
habe richtig gemerkt wie stark ich
geworden bin und ich habe auch einiges
abgenommen ich werde euch jetzt nicht
die zahl sagen denn darum soll es nicht
so wirklich gehen ich finde das ist ein
schwieriges thema aber ich werde den
sport auf jeden fall weitermachen und
wie feiert man am besten zwei monate
disziplin und sport natürlich mit einer
unmengen an kuka geht sogar mein
italienisches blut mit mir durch so sehr
freue ich mich gerade der starbucks
jetzt nicht kennt die machen halt café
die sind bekannt für ihren pumpkins
platte frappuccino und dafür dass sie
ihre größen anders nennen als jeder
andere kaffee marke die größen heißen
glaube ich toll fenty und grande falls
ihr euch gefragt habe ob ich eine basic
pitch bin jetzt wirst jetzt der cafés
ehrlich gesagt ganz gut er ist bei
manchen sorten ein bisschen über zucker
aber auch sehr überteuert da was tut mir
leid ich möchte trotzdem eine goldene
mitgliedskarte haben aber das muss schon
sagen das ist schon toll und jetzt
bringe man mir meinen ersten kuchen und
letzte frage bevor es losgeht was sagt
ihr zum einem kinosaal hintergrund sein
wenn du meine gardine
damit fahren wir an unser erster
kandidat heute ist die szene monroe von
starbucks
sie kostet zwei euro 69 sie ist ziemlich
groß und sie erinnert mich an diese
szene monroe dies noch in amerika gibt
von diesem laden der nur singles
verkauft falls euch das ein feld
schreibt mir die kommentare ich habe
schon drei laktose tabletten
eingeführten weil ich nicht weiß wie
viel milch drin aber wir probieren
einfach mal oder oh mein gott noch
fett und zucker und die muss man schön
warm essen damit sie so schön 20 ist ich
finde 269 aber schon zu teuer oder und
kann mich noch an zeiten erinnern da
hatten franzbrötchen 160 gekostet
bewertung von 10 ist schon richtig geil
ich wäre so weit zu den nächsten kuchen
danke ich dem lieben gott viel laktose
tabletten new york cheesecake und new
york cheesecake mit strawberry immer
wenn ich irgendwas von starbucks geholt
habe habe ich mir nie den geholt ich
halt keine laktose tabletten dabei hatte
oder sonst passt ich habe ihn noch nie
probiert gekostet hat er 91 dieses viel
ich habe meinem café gearbeitet da haben
die kugel stücke zwei euro fünfzig
gekostet und damals fand ich das schon
teur 91 ist schon ordentlich mal gucken
ob er auch wie 399 schmeckt wir haben
schon hier eine leichte trockenheit die
eingetreten ist erdbeeren ja gut das ist
hier aber zeitnah erstmal den normalen
hör mir auch ist das eine schönheit
leider habe ich in meinem leben noch
nicht so viele new york cheesecake
vergessen dass ich ihm vergleichen kann
aber das ist schon ziemlich lecker sehr
cremig schmeckt sehr nach weißer
schokolade irgendwie sehr butt ich jetzt
bin ich gespannt ob er mit den erdbeeren
noch besser schmeckt ja ich möchte gar
nicht so ein großes stück näher
kameraleute lebt nur einmal
ich finde ihn ohne erben besser wie rpm
haben so ein tiefkühl weit und deswegen
erinnert mich der strawberry cheesecake
an sohn erdbeerkuchen vom bäcker um die
ecke geht gar nicht es ist einfach
schlechte qualität diäten schmecken
nicht dass er nicht so mit frischen
erdbeeren machen sondern somit großmarkt
gekauft der normale der schmeckt
wirklich einfach wie eine sünde so was
was man ein wenig essen sollte
strawberry kate bekommt sechs von zehn
der bekommt sieben von zehn ja ich weiss
schlechter als das schnecken als
nächstes leute kommt der absolute
oberklasse eine vegane erdbeer schnitte
ich glaube starbucks hat sein veganes
angebot erweitern denn es gab das und
noch weitere die ich euch gleich zeige
aber jetzt erstmal vegane eröffnete
probieren dies ist sehr
kirche die hier die türen und quark
um an dieser schokokuchen boden schmeckt
einfach buchen dann ist da oben noch so
eine erbse drauf und so schoko drops
aber diese quarkcreme oder was ist hier
sein soll schmeckt als ob das backpulver
drin wäre aber das kann ja nicht sein
dass er kein backpulver dürfen man nicht
mich so gefreut also der preis pro mint
was wollen sie dafür dass das vegan ist
369 warum kostet cheesecake mehr als das
hier ist so viel aufwendiger denke ich
mal vom backen oder nehmen da muss man
ja soße und drops und so das ist doch
nur ja 93 aber es ist wenigstens schön
dass veganer hier nicht wieder abgezogen
werde wir müssen ja meistens immer mehr
bezahlen für die veganen alternativen
und hier hat man halt
und diese alternative bewerte ich mir
drei von zehn punkten ja
doch leute haltet ein dass vegane
angebot hört hier noch nicht auf es gibt
auch ein kirsch plunder ich jetzt sagen
muss dass sie irgendwie macht euch euer
eigenes bild darüber
99 war das einzige produkt mit einer 1
von herrn wir probieren sogar einsame
oben drauf ich bin sehr überrascht dass
sie ein bisschen helfen
also schmecken plunder irgendwie ist
also ein fed noch drauf mit gebacken
warum es dann so geil irgendwie ist
diese tisch creme ist absolut lecker
leinsamen sind schön crunchy blätterteig
ist gut gebacken dass er auch in
blätterteig für die schön knusprig ist
[Applaus]
diese kirsch gründer frisbee bekommt von
mir 9 von 10 punkten absolut
empfehlenswert quiz frage welches
produkt muss jedes franchise aus amerika
verkaufen ließ
genau ein cookie tatort und freddys
konnte er so heißt guter name wir haben
hier einen stabilen cookie der fast so
groß ist wie mein kopf gute
voraussetzung hat der koki bei
mcdonald's nicht früher auch ein euro
gekostet abo er ist ja eigentlich der
kuki meister und ich kann mir auch
irgendwie nicht vorstellen dass diese
guten kubica pol machen aber leicht
überzeugt uns der preis nein tut er
nicht naja 2029 nein es ist schon ganz
schön also man kann cookies wirklich
selber mache ich mein sohn new york ist
okay das ist noch kompliziert oder so
eine erdbeere schnitte oder so eine
plaudertasche dort gar keinen bock drauf
aber das hier ist ein bisschen butter
fett und zucker und dann im backofen
naja
sechs von zehn der ist jetzt wirklich
ist jetzt kein besonderer coup an der
schokolade diesen cookie dieses tui
weshalb der subway to be hat
hier kommt der muffin mehr sondern war
immer hier haben wir drei muffins von
starbuck raum chocolate cheesecake
muffin ein blueberry ganz klassisch und
ein mit himbeer der soll sogar vegan
sein und er hat sie ohnehin mehr saucen
keine ahnung was es damit auf sich hat
die probieren zuerst den chocolate
cheesecake glaube es war eine zeit an
der lieblings muffin von kelly fun fact
an der seite 3 auf 3 euro für drei bis
vier oder 33 euro für den disney portion
anderen dingen zu werfen kannst dann
probieren wir mal hier diese muffins für
drei euro
ich muss mal ganz kurz nur den schoko
muffins probieren
man hat ja halt so 1 schieß cache um
drauf wie bei dem new york cheesecake
ein schoko muffins der aber nicht
wirklich schokolade schmeckt also
relativ neutral und wieso typisch muffin
mäßig ich finde die kombination ist
wirklich nicht so gut und mir mehr
erwartet
ich bewerte ihn mit 77 ich finde der hat
gute sechs von zehn punkten verdient ich
wirklich mehr erwartet vielleicht bin
ich aber auch eher der typ blueberry
muffin blaubeeren in einem muffin das
ist einfach eine himmlische kombination
da braucht man gar nichts sagt damit
hier auch für 290 verkauf ich glaube das
ist absoluter buch abreise aber er ist
so schön als er schon groß das muss man
schon sagen
das ist
der bekommt 8 von 10 punkten von mir so
jetzt haben wir hier den veganen
kandidaten haben wenn du hier der vegane
was ist level raspberry muffin auf 290
es gibt richtig was an himbeeren zu
essen in der soße und irgendwie zitrone
noch mit drin findet es heraus
meinen mund brennt
ein von feldern punkten warum brennt
mein mund der schmeckt als ob der pause
mit in den teig rein gemacht wurde es
ist wirklich kein angenehmer
zitronengeschmack sondern ein in your
face es brennt ob man in die zitrone als
ahoi brause genau so komische zitronen
krümel drauf gemacht ich weiß nicht ob
ihr die sehen könnt sind so zitronen
krümel drauf
wäre ich enttäuscht wenn ich für 299
sommer verkaufen würde und dann schmeckt
er so scheußliches mich bei solchen
produktnummer frage da wird ja irgendwo
in irgendeinem labor das so getestet und
dann wird es an leute gegeben und dann
werde probieren das und sagen und wer
schreibt jetzt in die kommentare dass er
euch gut schmeckt probierst du einmal
denen himbeer zitronen machen
ja
so richtig so diese zitronen
findest du nicht das schmeckt wie ahoi
brause ein bisschen ja aber nicht so
unangenehm schon 18 punkte gibst du den
ich habe den 1 gegeben daran sieht man
mal wieder geschmäcker sind einfach
verschieden als nächstes gibt es mara
kuchen und zitronenkuchen weil ich ja
gerne zitronenkuchen asse wie ihr seht
was
kostet er marke 250 nähe nicht doch eine
scheibe im namen aller zu toren kommen
auch 250 pro scheibe und die sind jetzt
so ein bisschen
trocken aber riecht wie marmorkuchen
riechen sollte ich probiere erst mal den
mit schoko
schmeckt schon ein bisschen älter
verdienen okay er ist jetzt aber nichts
besonderes aber findet ihr das auch so
komisch dass bei mahnungen diese glasur
immer wieso eine schokoglasur aussieht
aber wirklich nicht so schokolade
schmeckt sondern ein auch nur wie fett
glasur man wenn man sich zum kaffee
kuchen trifft und die plaudertasche
ausverkauft ist kann man schon so ein
stück marmorkuchen nehmen und dann hat
man was solides leckeres aber es ist
jetzt nicht so ohne konnten ja wir haben
noch den walo kuchen übrig also jemand
von uns sehen ist gutscheine ich glaube
dass strom kommt mir auch nicht
schmecken ich habe das so ein bisschen
im gefühl dass die mit zitronen
übertreiben für meinen geschmack
[Musik]
hier geht es doch aber auch wieder
sofort trocken aber ich glaube das liegt
daran dass es jetzt schon so spät am tag
ist das ding ist sie schneiden ja den
marmorkuchen auch nicht vor ort ab wie
man es eigentlich machen sollte damit er
schön saftig bleibt sondern da sind
schon so vorgefertigte schnitte dieser
zitronenkuchen der schmeckt auf jeden
fall gut auch eine sieben von zehn
unser vorletzter kandidat
hab dein herz abonniert main kanal und
last ein leichter damit ich auch schön
weitermache mit diesem quality content
ich bin so happy ich habe eine anfrage
bekommen von der ich euch noch nicht
sagen darf weil sie noch nicht mal
hundert prozent sicher ist aber wenn das
klappen wenn ich wirklich der
glücklichste mensch auf der welt große
streubel an schon ein bisschen die farbe
abgegeben zwei euro fünfzig ich bin
nicht gut mit preisen ich verstehe es
nicht so ein donut verstehe ich auch
dass es mehr arbeitest du musst diesen
donnert den teig machen dann muss der
aufgehen dann musste ihn ausstanzen dann
musste im frittieren dann musst du diese
füllung machen dann muss man den glasur
um brauchen dann noch die streusel das
ist arbeit und vielleicht muss sogar
noch die glasur machen ist dabei es ist
alles vorgefertigter ware theoretisch
müsste man auch eine glasur man einen
zitronenkuchen musst du sechs zutaten
zusammengestutzt eine form krippen und
dann ist es fertig bin so auf den
backofen kommt und dann machst du dann
genauso drauf wieso ich
hier freunde
ich bin ich zu 100 prozent überzeugt der
schmeckt jetzt nicht schlecht aber ganz
ehrlich wenn man beim bäcker sich in
berlin erholt heißt berliner dann ist es
einfach liga die erdbeermarmelade
schmeckt besser also das ist wieso du
das auch mitspielen ja komm komm du das
auch mitspielen aber überzeugt nicht
aber so auch nicht wirklich verstehen
die falsches herz bekommt von mir ein
bisschen herz sechs von zehn profi naoki
mulgrew wien als
happy birthday to you ich irgendwas hat
heute geburtstag happy birthday to you
ich trinke auf dich
[Gelächter]
schokokuchen herren carrot cake ist
eigentlich board sieht ja genau hama uns
tröstet mal der politiker und so hat der
show guten abend ich nicht viel darüber
sagen er sieht aus wie der schokokuchen
aus dem matilda filmstars chocolate ii
den ich übrigens in meinem kochbuch auch
nach gemacht hat wollen die für ihren
kuchen für den carrot cake weil die vier
euro 19 uhr für den chocolate cake 391
so viel wie für den schießkeller ich
verstehe die preise nicht dass falls
jemand irgendwas mit starbucks zu tun
hat und irgendwie die preise
nachvollziehen kann schreibt sie gerne
in die kommentare so wie man ihn kennt
der ist nicht so wuchtig ist einfach der
sieht nett aus kein wunder dass sie
dafür für eure 19 haben wollen das ist
hier sogar der große teller und kleine
snacks obendrauf mit herbie börse tommy
der ist einfach saftig da passiert viel
er schmeckt nach zimt ja schmeckt ein
bisschen nach karotten der hat tolle
kerne nüsse irgendwas drin jetzt weiß
ich warum man gewinns kunis zehn von
zehn da könnt ihr mir nichts anderes
sagen ich glaube ich bin einfach jemand
der gerne zimt ist und nun das absolute
finale also das ist ein schokokuchen aus
zwei schichten dann haben sie noch
schokokuchen um draufgepackt inso
quadraten würfel und darüber haben sie
komplett einmal gut rüber gekippt und
wir übersehen die details nicht
schokoraspeln hinten drauf ist glaube
ich habe diesen kuchen auch schon mal
mit kelly in einem video getestet
tschüss bis morgen leute
ein bisschen trocken neun von zehn
sekunden ist einfach pure schokolade
reimann explosion war auch sehr teuer
das ding ist man kann bei starbucks
nicht mal eben sagen lass uns da an
kaffee und kuchen essen weil dann bist
du da einfach mal zehn euro los wie ein
café und stück kuchen so komische
starbucks zu den erfolgreichsten leben
gehört wenn es doch so teuer da ist ich
verstehe es einfach nicht ich hoffe euch
das video gefallen mir hat es definitiv
gefallen denn ich durfte ganz viel
kuchen essen und ich hoffe wir sehen uns
dann das nächste mal wieder eigentlich
war für heute ein anderes video geplant
aber wir mussten ein bisschen spontan um
entscheiden denn ich möchte ja nur die
allerbeste qualität für euch liefern
sehr gut jetzt abschalten das dann